Between The Wild Hunt, The White Flame, and
why everyone seems to want a piece of Ciri,
there are a lot of head-scratching moments
in the first five episodes of Season 3 of
"The Witcher."
Francesca lost her newborn daughter in Season
2, and that set off a series of catastrophic
events for not only the Elves but for everyone
who has come into contact with them.
After a tentative alliance with Nilfgaard
orchestrated by Fringilla, the Elves were
lulled into a false sense of security only
for devastation to ensue when her child was killed.
This led Francesca to lash out and kill several
Nilfgaardian children.
The reveal that the Nilfgaardian king, Ciri's
father, was the culprit in this horror makes
it all the more upsetting.
The grief over her child is overwhelming,
and it makes sense that Francesca's judgment
is completely compromised.
But no one else seems to be making particularly
good decisions either.
Francesca's only purpose now is revenge, but
that's all the more reason why her support
system should be stepping up and giving her
time to properly grieve.
We know that the Elves have had serious problems
with their leaders in the past, so it's kind
of surprising that there aren't better safeguards
in place for taking care of her.
Yet, the only attempts made to bring Francesca
back to her senses have been either gentle
coaxing or outright betrayal.
Both of these strategies have made the situation
drastically worse.
As it is, she's a mother who has lost not
just her child, but the hope for a better
future for her people, making her the most
dangerous kind of leader.
Maybe it isn't so much that Elf history is
confusing, just that we don't know all that
much about it, and everything we learn leaves
us with more questions.
For instance, "Blood Origin" did the handy
work of explaining a bit of context around
the Conjunction of the Spheres, an event that
saw worlds merge and delivered an influx of
humans and monsters to the world.
Even still, we get the feeling that the four-episode
spin-off only scratched the surface.
We met some major players and saw the beginning
of the decline of the Elven empire, but that's
a far way away from actually explaining the
full history of the Elves.
When Geralt is captured by Elves in the first
season, they're hanging on by a thread after
centuries of anti-Elf aggression and attacks.
In Season 3, we hear a bit more about Elven
history as Yennefer and Geralt tell Ciri the
tale of an ancient hero.
Even that legend seems entirely open to interpretation
as Ciri offers counterpoints to Yennefer's narrative.
When it comes to the Elves, we're getting
a lot of exposition in a very condensed format,
but if you have questions about what the Elves
have been up to since, well, forever, we're
right there with you.
Considering that they didn't particularly
want to be bothered by Geralt or his friends
to begin with, Codringer and Fenn's untimely
demise at the hands of Reince came as a bit
of a shock.
When Reince arrives at the library, it's not
clear what his true motives are for torching
the place and its occupants.
The two researchers gave Geralt only a sparse
amount of intel during his visit, but it costs
them their lives, and we can't help but feel
it was a bit of an escalation.
While it shows us that Reince is willing to
resort to abject cruelty to accomplish his
goals, we kind of already knew that.
We can't help but feel that these two were
of way more use alive than dead.
"Please, not the cat."
"Tell me everything."
All of our confusion around this one may be
rooted in our love for the lovably curmudgeonly
Codringher and Fenn, their cat, and their
stellar book collection, but their deaths
still feel like a bit of a waste.
Yennefer taking Ciri to Aretuza makes a lot
of sense.
It's clearly a decision she struggles with,
as does Geralt, but they agree together to
split up for the good of the Princess.
Yennefer takes her to train with the best
mages on the planet while Geralt goes after
Reince who continues to work in service to
a mysterious benefactor.
This is a choice they all struggle with, particularly
Yennefer, who knows the Brotherhood's hypocrisy
and balks at the idea of taking Ciri to them
despite her faith in their ability to keep
her safe.
Though Yennefer explains her own history to
Ciri, she doesn't prepare Geralt's adopted
daughter for how hard the mages are on their
novices.
She also doesn't fully explain the strange
political climate that made it such a struggle
for her to train there.
When Ciri first meets some of Yennefer's fellow
mages, she's immediately treated like a servant.
She bristles at this, and though Yennefer
explains to her that this is how you play
politics in the world of magic, it's not enough
to convince Ciri, who flees on horseback.
Though Ciri's brash flight from the town is
in character for her, it definitely exposes
a lack of understanding about the severity
of her situation.
Yennefer's feelings toward Tissaia, the Brotherhood,
and Aretuza are complex.
She views Tissaia both as a mother figure
and friend while still acknowledging her more
severe personality traits.
Life at Aretuza is what gave her power, but
she suffered at the hands of her teachers
and fellow students.
Finally, the Brotherhood has long served as
a thorn in her side due to its hubris and
unwillingness to change.
But she admires their power and sees herself
as one of them, even if she occasionally chafes
at the idea.
Tissaia's fondness and pride in Yennefer are
clear, but she continues to keep secrets from
her pupil.
This is certain to cause more harm to their
relationship.
Meanwhile, the Brotherhood watched Yennefer
almost single-handedly end the Battle of Sodden
Hill at the end of Season 1 only to more or
less put her on trial in Season 2.
In Season 3, they're universally annoyed by
her presence but most of the mages ultimately
see the benefits of her plea to a more united
Brotherhood.
By the end of Episode 5, it seems that she's
been invited back into the fold, but this
is a pretty tempestuous bunch of people, so
we'll have to wait and see.
This is one where we can rest assured that
we'll find out more about it soon, but that
doesn't change the fact that we still have
pretty much no clue what's going on with Ciri's
dad, the White Flame of Nilfgaard.
Perhaps the biggest twist of the second season
was the reveal that he was alive at all, with
Ciri believing that he and her mother perished
at sea many years before.
More shocking, he's the Emperor of Nilfgaard,
meaning that he's responsible for the damage
we've seen his invading army cause to the
Northern territories.
In the novels, the White Flame is fascinated
with his daughter's elder blood.
Her lineage inspires him to make choices that
are some of the most controversial plot points
of the book.
While the Netflix series has stayed relatively
true to the source material, it made a few
major deviations last season that clued us
in that there would be more changes on the way.
At present, all we know of Emperor Emhyr is
his glorified tale of taking back his kingdom
with the power of his sword, but he has a
tendency of being an unreliable narrator,
so we have to take his claims with a grain
of salt.
The build-up for the Wild Hunt has been extreme,
with "Blood Origin" diving into the distant
past in no small part to introduce us to the
"leader" of this mystical group of wraiths,
Eredin Bréacc Glas.
The captain of the Xin'trea military makes
several bad moves in a very short period of
time during the lead-in to the Conjunction
of the Spheres, and it costs him.
First, he plans a coup with Balor then sides
with Merwyn in hopes of securing a better
future for himself and his lover, Brian.
He is ultimately banished with several of
his men to an alternate dimension.
While we haven't seen much in the way of his
transformation to the leader of the Wild Hunt,
we can guess the story isn't a particularly
cheery one.
Though this season has given us glimpses of
the awesome power of the Hunt, and we know
that their pursuit of Ciri will continue,
we're still not sure what their ultimate goal is.
It's hinted that Ciri's power could act as
a key to unlock the barrier between realms,
but perhaps they want to induct Ciri into
their group.
Either way, we're still very much at the beginning
of their story.
"Child of the Elder Blood, starry-eyed daughter
of chaos, join our hunt."
When we first met Vilgefortz he was manipulating
Yennefer to return to Aretuza to help him
avoid being drafted into service by the king
of Nilfgaard.
After that, we saw him slay a fellow mage
during the Battle of Sodden Hill.
This created significant doubt about where
his loyalties lie.
While Tissaia sees the good in him, even that
has become fairly questionable at times, particularly
when he lashed out at her during Season 2.
Having taken leadership of the Brotherhood,
Vilgefortz seems calm through the first few
episodes of Season 3.
He even charms Yennefer who has good reason
not to trust him.
Using their shared love for Tissaia, he wins
Yennefer over, but to what end is still unclear.
Though there are plenty of theories swirling
around him as of the fifth episode, and there
might be a major blow-up on the horizon.
With Stregobor imprisoned for hiding a book
that he denies having taken, we suspect that
this could have easily been planted in his
room by Vilgefortz.
Cahir has been a mysterious character from
the start.
He lead the invasion of Cintra and attempted
to kidnap Ciri.
He continues his pursuit of Ciri and in his
search massacres a group of Cintran refugees.
He continues his rampage by enlisting a doppler
to kill Ciri's childhood mentor Mousesack
and take his form.
The doppler tricks her into trusting him but
traumatizes her by leveraging her only true
friend against her.
He later kills an entire tavern of people
just to make sure none of the people inside
are the doppler.
Without a doubt, Cahir is one of the most
terrifying characters in the series due to
his unsettling dedication to The White Flame.
In Season 2, he and Yennefer are forced to
flee together after she refuses to take his
life on behalf of the Brotherhood.
This sets off a chain of events that sees
him returning to Nilfgaard and allying himself
with the equally ruthless Fringilla.
When she murders several generals for treachery
but leaves Cahir alive, it becomes clear that
these two have some kind of connection, but
is it just their commitment to The White Flame?
We have seen time and again that Cahir will
do anything for the king of Nilfgaard, but
will discovering that Fringilla is still alive
despite the White Flamed claiming she has
died change any of that?
For someone who has appeared in so many episodes,
we still don't know much about what drives Cahir.
So far, we know very little of Philippa, making
her a confusing character.
We met her in Season 2 as an owl working in
tandem with Dijkstra, but as for what her
specific motivations are beyond a wild grab
for power, we're still pretty clueless.
We've seen her involved in S&M with Dijkstra
and engaging in an affair with one of Vizimir's
staff, and we know she's orchestrated more
than one brutal murder, but we still don't
know why.
One fascinating tidbit that has been dropped
in the third season is that she and Tissaia
had a falling out.
When Yennefer asks Tissaia what happened,
the mage dismisses what happened as two friends
simply growing apart.
"There's nothing to understand.
The friendship just ran its course."
Yet, Philippa seems to have plenty more to
say on the subject, leaving us to wonder what
exactly went down between these two powerful
mages.
And Philippa's mystery goes even deeper with
her connection to Aretuza and her unique mastery
over shapeshifting still mostly unexplained.
At this point, these plot threads could go
in just about any direction, so we're on the
edge of our seats with Philippa.